ultimately i mean it doesn't really
matter what round you take the player in
uh once he walks in the door uh you know
he's a new england patriot player and he
puts on the uniform and goes out there
and
and competes it doesn't matter if he's
in the second round or the fifth round
uh that really that doesn't matter once
he's on your team
friday edition pro football talk live
april 16 2021 also happens to be bill
belichick's birthday happy birthday
coach 69 years old peter king here today
mike florio
two hours and off we go you know peter
yesterday on pftpm
we started with a little clip from
belichick
and he smiled i did the
double take if i'd had water in my mouth
i would have done the classic
spit take bill belichick smiled he
seemed a little
looser yesterday he seemed a little more
friendly a little more gregarious
although he set the bar very low over
the years i was happy to see it it's
refreshing
to see bill belichick that way maybe
he's realizing
now that he's on the brink of 70. life's
too short to be miserable and
guarded all the time
i wouldn't count on it mike
[Laughter]
i think i think one of the great things
about
being away from you know the public
party or job
for four months basically
uh three months i should say being away
from the public part of your job
for that length of time you know you get
to basically say
hey look you know we've had a i've had a
big break okay we're back into it
you know the draft is here and so
edelman retired
i think he had a lot of kind of
of happiness slash goodwill
stored up and you know to me
i think bill is very good at the
sort of thoughtful and pensive parts of
the job
he's very bad at the uh dissecting
a loss at the end of a game when
something bad happened
uh you know he and i don't think i don't
think that
i don't think the latter is ever going
to change
but you're right it was good to see him
you know kind of almost bright and
cheerful yesterday
here's hoping he didn't completely empty
the tank of goodwill
yesterday and that maybe we'll see some
more of it from time to time but it
really was
refreshing to see and the guy is one of
the great coaches of all time and
who knows how much longer he will keep
going robert craft
told us at the league meetings four
years ago he'd like to see
bill belichick coach into his 80s i know
at one point belichick said he can't
imagine coaching at 70. different
feeling
when you're a year away from 70. he's
shown no sign of slowing down and i
think now
he's rejuvenated by what they've done in
the offseason as they try to rebuild
and and have another chapter of this run
of greatness the patriots
have had that's one of the things that
compels me the most this offseason peter
are we on the brink
of a new era where the patriots are
dominant or are they going to continue
to struggle
like we saw last year this is so foreign
to our experience
in the past two decades it's inherently
fascinating to watch how it all plays
out
look i think that's one of the reasons
why this draft is so important for new
england
you know how does this draft play out is
there going to be a quarterback
that bill belichick likes around
let's say 8 9 10.
you know are you going to see bill
belichick
or his dog nike pick up the phone and
call carolina at eight
denver at nine or dallas at 10
and try to move up and get pick one trey
lance mac jones
justin fields what are you going to see
as this draft goes on because
mike look you know bill belichick
once in his career if you look back
at the you know the drafts he's been
involved with
in cleveland and new england you know
tom brady
is the ultimate outlier the 199th pick
in the sixth round
of the 2000 draft that only happens once
you can't count on jimmy garoppolo and
jared stidham
and all that you know you can't count on
that so if you
see a quarterback and josh mcdaniels and
he
have been to most or all of the workouts
you know if you see a quarterback you
like you got to work hard
to go up and get them i am convinced
that
if baker mayfield had fallen
some you know in the draft three years
ago
uh four years ago now that the patriots
would have made a play and tried to go
get him but he would have he would have
had to fall
obviously well past number one and
i think this is the year being at number
15
where they're in position that they
could go get a quarterback
if one falls around eight nine and
look this is a this is one sad
list of of quarterbacks and of course
you see
when in bill belichick's time this will
be his
22nd draft in new england
and he's never used a first-round pick
on a quarterback
i think if if if one of them falls to
around eight nine
ten i think the patriot that they like i
think the patriots need to move
aggressively
dangle their first round pick in 2022
to try to go up and get it and that
really is the key
being at a starting point of 15
where it isn't quite as far to move to
get into that striking distance if
there's a guy you really like that slips
through
let's hear belichick himself from
yesterday some of that good will that
made its way into
his assessment of what the patriots
options are as they hold the 15th
overall selection in the 2021 draft
i think that it again each draft's a
little bit different and
and uh so each year is a little bit
different but
all that being said um
you know at 15 i think we could
eliminate a few players that won't be at
15
and then you could look at a couple
scenarios and say well if
you know these three players are there
which one we take if
these other three different players were
there which one would you take you know
you go through that exercise and and and
talk about that but
i would say normally something
now there's less options at 15 than
there are
you know 28 30 31 you know some other
spots that we drafted from but
um i would say normally something will
happen
and and there could very well be a
player there that
either you don't expect to be there
or maybe he is
a couple spots maybe at 12 13 he's still
on the board
and you really thought that he'd be gone
in the top six seven picks
and then that and you know then the
question comes
you know do you move up and try to get
that player that's falling a little bit
you know it occurred to me yesterday
when we played that sound on pftpm
that if you took that transcript and
gave it to frank caliendo and said read
this like john madden
it would work because there was a lot of
obvious there
and i could see that whole rhythm and
pattern fitting coach madden's way of
explaining things
but he's right he's right there at 15
they're rarely at 15 they're starting in
a spot that allows them
to get into the top ten if that guy they
like
bust through and part of the challenge
here is
you're gonna have teams in the top ten
that are tempted to overdraft
quarterbacks
reach for quarterbacks go earlier than
they should in the hopes of getting
lucky and finding a franchise guy that's
part of the philosophy that they're
competing with as they
apply that more strategic aspect to it
and peter we saw them break from
character
in free agency maybe they do break from
character
maybe they do have an element of roll
the dice
they want their franchise guy they're
willing to take their chance we're going
to be at 15
ideally once every 40 years let's take
advantage of that spot let's move up if
it works great if it doesn't
we'll find another way
i think the other part of this that's
going to be really interesting mike
is how aggressive uh
are teams down in the round
as well as how aggressive will the
patriots be because
right below them at 19 you've got
washington
at 20 you've got chicago both of those
teams i think chicago is probably
less likely you know to pillage future
drafts to move up for a quarterback
but i'm not so sure about washington i
think washington
is sort of laying there in the weeds
when you look at
pick number 19 right now you know
how much is washington willing to
uh affect future drafts if a quarterback
that they like a lot
is going to be there around excuse me
around 11
12 13. could they move up could they
leapfrog new england
and you know what mike the one other
thing about new england
is they do the best job in my opinion of
any team in the nfl of hiding their
intentions before the draft
so i'm not gonna know you're not gonna
know we're just
you know we're gonna have to wait until
they open the gifts on christmas day
in 13 days yeah chris sims has explained
in the past that when he worked there
how the
circle of people who actually knew what
belichick's board was
was extremely small and they kept that
information away
from anyone else in the building people
who otherwise would be trusted
not trusted with that information a
little extra pressure in the building
this year by virtue
of comments that were made a couple of
weeks back from owner robert kraft
candid biting criticism of the team's
recent
experiences in the draft inability to
draft an ability to develop as well i
think that's part of it we need to keep
in mind
here's bill belichick talking about the
struggles that the patriots have had on
draft day in recent years
well we're always you know always
looking to do to get better
um always try to evaluate everything we
do and try to find a better way to to do
it
so that's that's a i would say an annual
process with the draft but it's
something that we do
on a regular basis throughout the course
of the season whether it's
you know whatever period of time it is
so um
you know always looking to to do a
better job there were some things that
last year that were unique to the draft
process as i mentioned some of those are
similar this year some of them are a
little bit different
so we you know certainly
use some of that experience to uh
improve the process a little bit this
year at least we felt we improved it
this year
um but ultimately we're still going to
try to
you know evaluate the players and and
make the decisions that
we feel like we're best for the football
team
the departure of nick casario the vp of
player personnel since 2009
forced some of those changes but also
the first round picks the team
has exercised in recent years getting
them to take a closer look at what
they're doing how they're doing it
there was a report from albert breer a
couple of weeks ago that bill belichick
went off the board to take and kill
harry at receiver in the first round two
years ago when aj brown and debo samuel
were more highly rated by the team
scouts and peter the other angle of this
that fascinates me
belichick talked about how matt patricia
the former lions coach who before that
was a long time assistant coach in new
england
is heavily involved in the draft and as
of a couple of weeks ago there were
reports that
patricia was negotiating free agent
contracts
signing his name to the deals like the
cam newton contract
patricia's becoming like another version
of ernie adams where we're not really
quite sure what he does
but he's doing a lot of things to
support the cause in new england
when when matt patricia interviewed for
a job with the rams a few years ago i
forget i think it was the year that they
hired
uh i think it was the year that they
hired sean mcvay in their round of
interviews
that year patricia was interviewed by
the rams and the rams walked away
and i remember thinking this at the time
what an odd
kind of conclusion but the rams walked
away and said matt patricia would be a
really good general manager
he sees the entire organization you know
and and a lot of their conversation that
day was about that
and mike i want to go back on one of the
things that you said
uh you know before belichick's last bite
and that is this
i will never forget covering the draft
10 years ago
not i was not in foxboro or you know i
wasn't i wasn't around the patriots
but i do remember one very specific
story about that draft
that was a draft they took nate solder
in the first round
and in the second round um they had a
high
second round pick and they chose a
cornerback an
oft injured cornerback from virginia
named ross i dowling
and when that pick was made a lot of the
team scouts
you know who are as you say in new
england
it is a need to know basis organization
you know those guys do not know what
bill belichick's board says
and jaws hit the floor when
they picked ross i dowling because the
scouts were positive that year
they were going to take a pass rusher
like jabal sheared or brooks reed
and and when they heard that pick they
all
they had no idea whatsoever that rossei
dowling was
even in play you know to get picked and
so
that's why you know it's somebody
for people who say man if you have good
sources inside the patriots
this is the year you got to use them i
don't think it matters
there's only one source inside the
patriots you know
and and he's he's not going to talk
before the draft
so you know at least talk openly
honestly
so i do think this is really one of the
one of the mystery teams going into the
draft as it is every year
and peter it reminds me of the story
from a couple of years ago when mike
mayok was the gm of the raiders for his
first draft and it was a big deal for a
news cycle or two
that they sent everyone else home the
week before the draft and sims and i
concluded
that that was motivated in large part by
the fact that john gruden
can't keep his mouth shut in the
building and feels compelled
to go around office to office talking
coach to coach and scout the scout to
make sure that that they agree with how
he sees things
belichick doesn't need that he's got so
much conviction in what he believes
and maybe to a fault maybe he would
benefit
from getting the perspective of others
he just doesn't trust them
so he doesn't share it and that could
lead to some of these decisions like in
kiel harry where he really didn't talk
it through with anyone
because he didn't want anyone to know
what he was thinking
look there's a long line of decisions
that have been made over the years
uh by people who don't want anybody else
to know
the year that mike shanahan chose jay
cutler in the draft
nobody in his organization knew until 11
o'clock that morning
and and i mean nobody not even ownership
and so that is that's how you keep a
secret
you talk about mike mayok in that
particular draft
you're absolutely right mike you know he
didn't want anybody in the organization
knowing what they were going to do and
calling their buddies on other teams
but i also think there was another
reason too
that by that time mike mayok had
determined
that there were x number of scouts and
some people who probably weren't going
to be around very long
you know with the raiders uh either for
whatever reason
he had somebody else he thought could do
a better job
maybe these guys had gotten used to
cutting corners
with the raiders over the years who
knows but
i do recall that very specifically and i
and i really remember because i was in
oakland
uh after the first round of that draft
and had a long conversation with mayok
mayak was very convinced that this
organization
had to get the ability to keep secrets
and so i i i think you and chris were
writing what you thought
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports